um
seriously
more i'm just capturing the moment
he's all that is making netflix viewers
all over the world swoon over this high
school romance what do you think
i think yes starring addison ray in her
acting debut and tanner buchanan this
remake of the hit teen rom-com she's all
that switches the roles around and gives
the fan favorite high school romance a
much needed facelift
good morning guys it's me paget head to
toe here while he's all that maybe her
very first feature film addison ray was
already a household name by the time she
was cast in the role of paget sawyer
addison ray got her start on tiktok and
has a massive fan base of over 83
million followers making her the second
biggest creator on the popular app no
i've really wanted to this my entire
life rey even looked towards rom-com
veterans such as julia roberts and
jennifer aniston for inspiration for her
role in the film thank you for this
morning my butt is so sore i could
barely walk one of the biggest cameos
and he's all that is definitely the
inclusion of kourtney kardashian as
paget's sponsor kardashian took the role
later in the casting process with rey
suggesting to the film's producers that
it could be fun to have people from her
personal life make appearances in the
film look we pay you because you're the
makeover girl once kardashian's name was
brought up rey became extremely excited
about the thought of working with her
the role matched perfectly with kind of
how we are in real life she is an
amazing friend of mine she's an amazing
mentor and person i was like oh my gosh
we have to get courtney in this movie
one of the most memorable scenes and
he's all that may just be the dance
battle scene that takes place at the
prom
we have some weird ass traditions at
this school
this scene took quite a bit of rehearsal
with the actors and dancers having to go
through plenty of practice before the
scene was ultimately filmed on set in
front of the cameras i've been putting
out this image of this perfect person
it's all fake the set of he's all that
did have some drama along the way in
regards to addison ray according to an
extra in the film rey would often
struggle with trying to remember all her
lines which would require multiple takes
everyone even like the main actors were
getting low-key annoyed it even got to
the point where director mark waters had
to physically show rey the script just
so she could remember exactly what she
was supposed to say oh my that is a lot
of case with it being her first movie
it's not too surprising that she'd mess
up on her lines it's all part of the
experience after all yeah i guess you
guess he's all that was filmed in los
angeles on december of 2020 which was
right in the midst of covet 19. with
cases spiking all across the city in
order for filming to go as smoothly and
efficiently as possible all 170 of the
film's cast and crew had to participate
in daily testing so there'd be no snags
down the road the testing center used
was initially closed off for just the
cast and crew but that decision was
reversed not long after filming began
don't forget your camera
no no no no
one of the most challenging scenes to
film for he's all that was the scene
where cameron falls into a pool and has
an intense confrontation with paget why
after four years did you suddenly start
talking to me
i don't know
the scene was filmed late at night
between midnight and 6 a.m and the
weather was unexpectedly very cold at 45
degrees fahrenheit on top of tanner
buchanan already having to wear a suit
drenched in water buchanan would have
drenched himself in the shower and would
have to redo the scene several times all
within the span of a night so that was
the most challenging one that wasn't
that wasn't the most pleasant while
addison ray may have had to audition in
person for the main role many of the
other young adult cast members had to
audition virtually over zoom rey even
had to do her chemistry test with tanner
buchanan digitally this definitely made
things tougher for director mark waters
to select who was right for the part we
still ended up i think making the right
choices but it was definitely a stickier
process than usual i was hoping to take
a writing lesson this morning and i
figured since you and i are friends uh
friends there's been plenty of times
where films with romantic anchor will
feature two performers who share zero
chemistry with one another making for an
awkward shoot wow you don't see that
every day fortunately that wasn't the
case for addison ray and tanner buchanan
on the set of he's all that we got to
know each other super quick we dove
right in we got to know each other and
the crazy things and the deep things and
yeah i mean we had a blast together
payton meyer was initially very wary of
joining the film particularly because
he's not a social media person his knack
to avoid the social media frenzy also
made him very skeptical about working
with a major tick-tock star like addison
ray but that quickly changed the first
day i met her it just all washed away
she was so sweet and you could tell she
was laser focused she's great to work
with we're glad meyer was able to change
his mind that's the truth we belong
together hatch a she's all that remake
wouldn't really be the same without
dancing and while addison is known for
showing off her moves on tiktok all eyes
were on tanner buchanan buchanan just so
happens to have some experience with
professional tap dancing he would even
go as far as to bust out his tap shoes
in between takes and show off his moves
to the cast and crew maybe he showed off
some of his cobra kai karate moves as
well oh
that one's really hard as paget and
cameron begin to truly bond and he's all
that they share a karaoke duet to the
katy perry tune teenage dream initially
the song was supposed to be the kelly
clarkson hit since you've been gone
although tanner buchanan and addison rey
felt that the parry song would be a much
better fit for the movie you have a
really great voice i know there's a
secret one of the most pleasant
surprises of he's all that was the
return of rachel lee cook and matthew
lillard who were two of the stars of
she's all that though unlike many other
reboots cook and lillard weren't
reprising their original roles instead
cook took on the role of paget's mom
while lillard would play the high school
principal is that it
yeah of course it is cook was initially
skeptical about joining the film and
wasn't sure if she wanted to return to
the story joking that it might bruise
her ego but that quickly changed overall
it was just really important to me to be
of support to this new cast and what
they're doing it does seem like the cast
if he's all that became very close while
filming much like the cast if she's all
that did in fact the cast still stays in
touch to this day and have extremely
fond memories of working together on set
we text each other we have a group chat
and every time one of us is in town
we're like let's all go do something
we're all still super good friends
great you guys came yes
we did the writer and director behind
he's all that are no strangers to giving
audiences some fan favorite teen movies
director mark waters is very experienced
in the field he even directed mean girls
a staple of the genre along with the
2003 remake of freaky friday
screenwriter r lee fleming jr had
actually written the original film as
well and returned for the remake he was
also responsible for writing the
screenplay of another teen rom-com get
over it this made the pair the perfect
fit to tackle the modern take on the
story you know you could totally make
money at this right you know i don't
care about money tanner buchanan had
already made waves on netflix in his hit
series cobra kai as robbie keane the
emotionally complex son of johnny
lawrence the producers behind he's all
that were already huge fans of the
karate kid sequel series and set him up
for an audition because of just how much
they loved him on the show this is
insane you're hot now get used to it
maybe if they do a sequel we can get
sholo maraduena to appear as well that
actually sounds amazing from auditioning
virtually breaking down barriers and
filming in the midst of a pandemic
making he's all that didn't seem to be
the easiest task but that didn't stop
the cast and crew from having a great
time on set what was your favorite
moment from he's all that
what it's mostly grass right